[Musique]
depuis que vous entraînez de nuit
simplement une prière pour le repos de
l'âme de christelle cinq mois après
manille n'a toujours pas fait son deuil
une fois par semaine sur ce terrain
vague faisant office de cimetière elle
se recueille avec ses deux petits fils
sur la tombe de sa fille assassinée en
octobre 2021
christelle avait 24 ans lorsqu'elle a
été poignardé à mort par son ex petit
ami dans ce quartier de douala leurs
deux fils ont longtemps été témoin des
violences que subissent est leur mère
tapez 1 tapez 1 méthadone dans les
cadeaux d'appui âgés de 4 et 8 ans ils
ont assisté impuissant à l'assassinât de
leur maman un jeu comme ça chez vous la
fermez la porte une fois qu'on commet
une bisque et on voit que c'est à lui et
à la trappe est resté comme ça après mam
elle a posé la question qui était dit
les pv sur moi il est fâché les enfants
pour le couteau et l'a rejoint sur
auprès de ma mère la station est
désormais en prison mais manny la grande
mer continue de ressentir une profonde
injustice la disparition de sa fille a
été aussi brutal qu'inattendu christelle
était le pilier financier de sa famille
sa mère sans emploi est aujourd'hui
réduite à la quasi m'ont dit si tu es
pour survivre voici depuis comme affirma
toute ma vie est finie c'était ma mère
était tout pour moi qui faisais tout
pour moi mais la crise tant que parti
analysé dans la rue avec les enfants
c'est le cas de ceux qui dominent
souvent les méchants les 2000 que je
peux pas il vous faut aussi dans le noir
quand christelle au moins 130 femmes ont
été tuées par leur conjoint au cameroun
entre 2019 et 2020 selon un décompte de
la commission nationale des droits de
l'homme celles qui ont échappé à la mort
sont marqués à vie cette jeune femme que
nous appellerons charlotte un prénom
d'emprunt a réussi à fuir son foyer avec
ses trois enfants pour échapper aux
coups de son ex mari elle est une des
rares à vouloir témoigner mais a décidé
de le faire sous anonymat il y encore
quelques semaines elle a échappé à la
mort après avoir été frappé par son ex
époux ce jour là il a attaqué à la
machette et elle n'a eu la vie sauve que
grâce à l'intervention du ses enfants et
la playmate y est malin avec pas at on
est quand même à se lever le coup de
grâce le coupé la tête alors les enfants
sont levés d'autant était le piano
d'arrêter les bras pour que papa
définies par les finis par le sens
fatigué de voir le sang depuis cette
tentative d'assassinât survenu en 2018
elle vit caché la peur au ventre car son
compagnon au contenu à la traquer comme
de nombreuses victimes de violences et
crimes conjugaux cameroun elle ne
bénéficie d'aucun dispositif de
protection pour l'éloigner ou la mettre
à l'abri des menaces de son ex conjointe
il est fait les suivre parce que j'ai
déménagé même l'échangé de maison pour
éviter l'alcool même menacer les enfants
prenaient lie à la nouvelle maison les
enfants ont dit jamais une semaine à
divo et mais c'est con mais c'est pas
d'y penser j'ai pas la paix une paix
difficile à trouver pour ces femmes
victimes de violences conjugales la
plupart livrée à elle même sans aucun
recours judiciaire on ne peut pas nier
le faire pétrissez fed et menacer
la justice un parcours de combattant
pour celles qui osent porter plainte
comme charlotte elles sont encore trop
peu nombreuses à pousser les portes de
cabinet d'avocats comme celui de m
charlotte qui a compté les plus de 30
ans et avocate camerounaise mène une
bataille judiciaire pour prévenir les
féminicides un accompagnons des femmes
victimes de violence conjugale avec un
émotif intervenir avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard est ce que vous avez pensé à
cesser les autorités
et puisque
le problème est bizarre
oui mais le problème qui au tribunal
porte sur des grosses plus sûres il vous
a posé à l'aide de la manette alors
aujourd'hui il apprend le commettre
d'autres faits pour lesquels vous devez
saisir les autorités les menaces qui
refait ne sont pas fondées ce jour-là
elle reçoit charlotte qui vient chercher
une assistance juridique pour mettre
hors d'état de nuire son ex mari violent
maître tient compte et reçoit ainsi des
dizaines de femmes chaque mois à qui
elle prodigue bénévolement des conseils
et qu'elle accompagne dans leurs
démarches judiciaires souvent son succès
le nombre de féminicide ne cesse
d'augmenter et l'avocate attribue cette
hausse à l'impunité judiciaire dont
bénéficie les conjoints dans un système
très patriarcale effectivement avec
montée de violence allant jusqu'aux
jusqu'à la mort des femmes c'est c'est
très inquiétant
malheureusement nous ne savons plus quoi
faire parce que malgré la multitude des
lois nous avons l'impression que nos
concitoyens ne sont pas concernés ils
sont nombreux cela qui
pose ses essais et ses actes criminels
mais qui reste en liberté qui circulent
à la minute qui se moque et de la
victime et de la loi au nom de la sonde
il peut avoir est donné à tout le monde
affaire classée sans suite procédure qui
s'éternise d'après les défenseurs des
victimes les failles de l'institution
judiciaire expliquerait le faible nombre
de féministes officiellement déclarés
dans ce pays plusieurs fois classé parmi
les plus corrompus dans le monde